In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxarion for May 10th, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle
Simon the Zealot.
On the 10th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostle Simon Zealots.
According to an ancient tradition, Saint Simon Zealots, mentioned by Saint Luke among the
Twelve Apostles, was the bridegroom of the wedding in Cana of Galilee, for whom Christ worked
the first miracle of this public ministry by changing water into wine.
Seeing this miracle, Simon believed with all his heart, and he abandoned wife, house,
and country to follow Christ, the heavenly bridegroom of pure souls.
On the day of Pentecost, he was with the other Apostles in the upper room, and received
the gift of the Holy Spirit in the form of tongues of fire.
Then truly filled with the divine zeal for the salvation of his brothers and sisters, he
left to preach the good news in every part of the world, and especially in Africa, where
he evangelized all Mauritania and Libya.
It is said that he then traveled as far as Great Britain, where he enlightened numerous
pagans by his preaching.
He was crucified by idol worshipers in imitation of his master and was buried in that land, becoming
the seed of the Christianity that was to develop there.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.